oh here's that guy again last time he
was at the game that was completely
deserted
1 Ernest if wondering if we enjoyed
watching hockey out and win wondered if
you want season ticket yeah we wanted
season tickets to watch the Toledo
empties play it
Kirsti I'll be VI season tickets to
Cleveland little Debbie's 7 people crowd
are they really yeah what do you got yo
what's up boys listen up it's Tom Durant
back here for a little Redemption after
last week's Ontario rain game tonight
Staples Center baby we got DJ loop a
loop in the back there Los Angeles King
King it or sing it national league
hockey you can't sing the king baby
Jane King buzz buzz I love it yeah yeah
yeah and there really is Snoop right
there where I think he sent another
video let me see if I can find it DJ
snoop well I'll go this on the Kings man
the Kings are not a good team right now
but they got a lot they just did a big
overhaul they got rid of a lot of older
guys with added some heavy contracts
they got a lot of a lot of young guys
right now that are starting to really
kind of meld together and um I like the
vibe man I think they got a good future
over there for the pie I like NHL hockey
it's the best sport to see live you
could throw a carp on the on on ice yeah
you might so are they still octopus on
ice remember that you could still hum a
damn sardine out there if you find you
throw any [ __ ] animal you want really
as only comes from the sea okay throw a
little [ __ ] stingray out there like a
sneak and anchovy out in that [ __ ] bro
grouper a grill dog you score a
hat-trick up on a [ __ ] puffer fish oh
dude [ __ ] [ __ ] put it huh I'll put
a damn what does that call oh I know a
joke oh no I'll put a damn penguin in a
hard scarf and throw that [ __ ] that's
the hard scarf brother yeah
rear naked choke and I'll do that fully
front and rear naked choke bro fully
naked I'll shut the whole goddamn game
down throw a [ __ ] wall or something
yeah he's bro you score a hat-trick oh
[ __ ]
you can attune out there I can't call
somebody's mama [ __ ] call that little
ice [ __ ] opera [ __ ] hot basket of
fish tenders out there son
y'all throw some [ __ ] fish and chips
and call your mom [ __ ] little puss
whole stupid loops fantastic dude NHL
I'm all for it
I'm all for again real house to get to
the game but once I'm there I'm happy
I'm all for it
yeah it's a little hassle getting there
it's a beast
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]